[Music]
last november netflix delivered a big
hit with the action comedy red notice
the lineup of ryan reynolds gal gadot
and dwayne johnson won over viewers not
only thanks to the fame but also because
of their shallow and rather mainstream
action in fact the movie seems to be
such a huge success that netflix decided
to go ahead with not only one but two
sequels as reported by the use magazine
deadline according to the report johnson
will return as john hartley reynolds as
nolan booth and gedot as sarah black the
story about the most wanted criminals in
the world and the cat and mouse game
with the police will then probably be
expanded to include some other big names
similar to what we know from the ocean's
film series for example exactly how the
plot will carry on is not yet clear but
we strongly assume that the story will
continue in paris as netflix confirmed
the two sequels will be shot back to
back meaning all in one chunk this year
however it seems that there will be no
filming because it is not scheduled to
start before early 2023 the releases
thus unfortunately not to be expected
before the end of 2023
in november 2017 work on the lord of the
rings series was officially announced
and this year we can at least watch the
first season exclusively on amazon prime
video all the better that in the
meantime not only the official title the
lord of the rings the rings of power is
known but also a first teaser was
published the just under one minute clip
was unexpectedly released last wednesday
and caused great excitement due to the
usual epic style in terms of content
this series deals with the legendary
second age of middle-earth for the first
time on screen the story of the rings of
power thus takes place thousands of
years before the events of the hobbit or
peter jackson's the lord of the rings
trilogy amazon says that the series
begins in a time of peace in which we
will also get to see some old familiar
characters such as galadriel the initial
piece however should quickly turn around
to the opposite because there's also
mention of the long feared return of
evil which should refer to none other
than sauron a special treat for the eyes
will also be the vast landscape of
middle earth which stretches from the
darkest depth of the misty mountains to
the majestic forests of linden and the
breathtaking island kingdom of numenor
as amazon itself announced however some
questions are still left unanswered for
instance it is not clear whether the
current cannon will be kept or discarded
all this is to be found out later this
summer because the lord of the rings the
rings of power will air on september 2nd
2022 exclusively on amazon prime
before the end of the year we will be
able to enjoy the new dc sequel aquaman
and the lost kingdom in theaters on
instagram director james juan now shared
a sheery picture from the last day of
shooting where he can be seen alongside
patrick wilson and jason momoa on the
beach in malibu the dc executives must
have high hopes for the new equipment
because if you look at the past films
like birds of prey of the suicide squad
they have either produced flops in the
recent past or thrilled to mess with
movies like joker in between there was
basically nothing and to be honest joker
is not really part of the dceu and
completely stands on its own aquaman
from 2018 on the other hand is the most
successful dc film of all time with box
office takings of 1.1 billion us dollars
which of course has also to do with the
extremely popular jason momoa in
addition to the obligatory words of
thanks to the cast and crew in the
instagram post one also emphasized that
the movie still has a long way to go
before it's truly ready for the big
screen in terms of content aquaman and
the lost kingdom once again revolves
around the titular superhero arthur
curry who is the new king of atlantis
following the defeat of his half-brother
or marius pretty soon it becomes clear
that the two feuding characters will
have to team up after all as a long
hidden force is threatening atlantis and
in fact the entire world in addition to
momoa and wilson we will be able to see
among others dolph lundgren as king
nurius nicole kidman as queen atlanta
yaya abdulmuddin ii has black manta and
last but not least amber her desmara who
is widely scorned in the fan community
the screenplay is once again written by
david leslie johnson mcgoldrick while
production is also directed by peter
safran alongside james wong aquaman and
the lost kingdom will hit theaters on
december 16th 2022
we can look forward to the new black
panther wakanda forever at the end of
this year and it seems that an actress
who was thought to be out of action is
now returning to the set we are of
course talking about leticia wright who
as we reported last year injured herself
so severely during filming that she was
unable to perform for months a return
was not foreseeable until now also
because she made statements about the
covert vaccination which gave the
responsible people at disney headaches
now the 28 year old british actress has
fought her way back which should
especially please those involved in the
production after all shooting was
completely on hold for the time being
because of her important role as shuri
in particular the fact that shuri is the
sister of king t'challa who as everyone
knows was embodied by chadwick boseman
who passed away in 2020 may have finally
prompted the responsible parties to let
her return in fact there's a persistent
theory that shuri has to follow in the
footsteps of her brother t'challa and
that she will therefore play a very
important almost irreplaceable role in
black panther wakanda forever whether
right and her character shuri will
continue to play a role in the mcu after
the black panther sequel is unlikely as
disney and especially the mcu are not
known for tolerating divergent and
controversial opinions in the ranks for
now however filming continues in atlanta
and we're definitely excited to see
latisha right back for roll black
panther wakanda forever will be released
in theaters on november 11 2022
this year not only the batman will be
released in theaters its female
counterpart batgirl will also soon
celebrate her premiere in the form of a
new movie the movie will be directed by
bad boys for life directors ariel arby
and bilal fala who will release the dc
blockbuster on hbo max despite the
extremely prominent cast which in
addition to leading actress leslie
grace's batgirl also features stars like
jk simmons as her father james gordon
brandon fraser as the villain firefly
and michael keaton as batman it appears
that a theatrical release is still
unlikely filming is currently taking
place in glasgow scotland where we were
finally treated to a first image of
batgirl a few days ago the outfit
appears not to be very close to the
original comic but that should
definitely not them in our anticipation
for the film there's currently no
concrete release date for batgirl
although we can probably expect a
release on hbo max this year
just about everyone knows the frozen
song let it go which was magnificently
sung by u.s star idina mensle and surely
played in millions of children's rooms
one could almost think that this is the
most successful disney song of all time
but we were taught otherwise this week
as revealed by the u's billboard charge
the title song of ancanto called we
don't talk about bruno is now the most
successful disney song in over 26 years
the first spot on the us charge
certainly does justice to this planet
animated film as it was able to convince
critics and disney fans alike in spite
of the circumstances which were not
always simple due to the pandemic the
tick tock platform probably played a
significant part in the success as the
hashtag encanto really took off there
with billions of views if you have a
disney plus subscription and haven't
seen the film yet you should do so
quickly and not just because of the
highly popular theme song
slowly but surely the production of the
last of our series is progressing as
those responsibly confirmed storm reed
who is only 18 years old is now part of
the cast it is furthermore known that
she will embody the role of ellie's
friend riley abel which surprised many
fans while riley is not a part of the
two main games she does appear in a dlc
of the first part called left behind
where the young girls heartwarming but
ultimately tragic story is told the dlc
is set a few weeks before the events of
the first part and takes place in an
abandoned mall in boston where the two
best friends perfectly combine emotional
conversations with funny actions in a
video that circulated on twitter back on
january 10th a scene strongly
reminiscent of that very mall was seen
in the background a few days ago an
appearance by riley was then officially
confirmed it is therefore quite possible
that the content of the upcoming series
will start off with left behind or
alternatively that the story of the dlc
will be used for various flashbacks
however this series is supposed to
revolve around the story of the first
part and the two main characters joel
and ellie who have to fight their way
west through the united states in order
to reach a research facility in addition
to pedro pascals joel and balaram say as
ellie the cast also includes gabriel
luna as joe's brother tommy anna dwarf
as tess and con o'neal as bill it is not
known yet when exactly the series by
chernobyl traitor craig mazin and neil
druckmann will be out but we will of
course keep you up to
date so that's it with our news for this
week of course do not miss to have a
look at the aforementioned teaser for
the lord of the rings series on our
channel in addition there's a new moon
knight trailer check it out marvel fans
are in for a treat
[Music]